i i suppose we can get started it's
almost five after the
advertised hour um so welcome everyone
to this uh finale of the synthesis
workshop at the simons institute
um so it's been it's been quite a
journey we have explored many topics and
synthesis
over the semester and uh and today we
have a distinguished panel of five
speakers
that cover um i would say most
of the topics that we have seen during
this
uh this series in the semester
um so um the plan for today is we're
gonna have
uh at the beginning ten-minute
statements from each of our five
panelists
so that should take about an hour and
then we have
uh you know anywhere from uh half an
hour to more
um for q a and discussion and we really
want this to be something where
everybody engages we have more of a
discussion
um so if you have questions uh during
the panelists
uh of course i think we'll have a short
q a after each panelist just for
clarification stuff but
if you have really you know uh questions
that you think will
stroke a lot of discussion and so forth
which we hope we'll try to defer them to
the end but you're welcome to ask those
questions during the panelist statements
um and then at the end uh i think
everybody is a speaker
right so don't hesitate to raise your
hand unmute
and speak i know some people attendees
probably cannot unmute themselves that's
just the way it is
it's arranged here but please do put
your questions and
one of us organizers will read that
question for you
okay and so we really hope that that
second um
hour uh becomes the really engaging
uh and uh super finale of this workshop
all right so without further ado uh let
me
go ahead and begin and um
uh it's i'll we'll stop we're figuring
out the order of uh
panelists presentations uh on the fly
here
and so uh we will begin with uh
professor ordna cooperman
um so it's my great pleasure to
introduce ordna whom i've known for
many many years and arna
is a professor at the hebrew university
of jerusalem
she's worked on many aspects of formal
methods
automata theory and other theoretical
aspects of formal methods
but he's been one of the pioneers in the
field of synthesis particularly reactive
synthesis
uh working on many foundational topics
in in reactive synthesis of
all the way from logics to algorithms
and
decidability and complexity results so
uh or not please go ahead whenever
you're ready
um and we can begin your 10 minute
statement
okay thank you very much thank you for
inviting me to speak i actually have
some slides
so if i uh share
screen i can do it right i think so
yeah it's coming up yes and it even
works right yeah perfect
yes okay good uh so
so you all know that uh in there are two
main questions informal verification
one is verification itself where we have
both the system and the specification
and we ask whether the system satisfies
the specification
and then in synthesis we have only the
specification
and we ask whether there is a system
that satisfies the specification and if
there is such a system
we want to return it this is a very
important distinction yes the fact that
in
verification we have the system and the
specification in synthesis only the
specification
because both the system and the
specification describe the behaviors
of the system they only do it at
different levels
of obstructions so so if you want you
can view synthesis
as the art of criticizing an abstract
description
of a system because you can think about
temporal logic or anything you use in
order to specify the requirements also
as a
programming language only that it's a
very abstract one
and then what we do in synthesis is we
take this program
that is a specification but it is not
executable but
it describes the system and we can
criticize it
we say okay now we need program counters
now we need semaphores we need queues
these are all kinds of more programming
or design
issues that we need in order to
criticize the abstract description
of the system and if we take this
approach
of the system and the specification both
describing
the behavior and synthesis is just
the challenge of getting rid of the
abstract things that need to be
implemented then there are all kinds of
traditional concerns
about this process and then this is the
fact that okay
we want the system to be correct who
synthesizes the specification
it's just another level in this process
of generating the
the system so that was a traditional
concern
and we are not too worried about it we
are not too worried about it because
we we understand uh that okay this is
the deal
uh and describing an abstract thing is
much easier than designing the system
this is exactly the point we want the
synthesis algorithm
to invent semaphore to invent cues and
everything we need
in order to implement our requirement
so if you want you can view synthesis
something that let the designer
focus more on what we want the uh the
system to do and less on how
so this is what we want to automate
still
there are many challenges here yes
sanity checks
is our specification really good is it
exhaustive
there are people that claim that we
don't need this approach of
the specification describing
uh the system but perhaps something that
is more scenario-based
perhaps we should develop something they
the go specification and
you can each interpret it as you want
but it's something that where we
don't specify things in the middle
uh so so that's one concern and another
concern is the fact that this
transition is very complex for example
if we start with ltn
and we want to move to transfer cells it
is doubly exponential
but here again we can view it as a plus
the fact that the translation is doubly
exponential means that
we do the job yeah the the specification
is indeed much more abstract
uh the other way around perhaps we can
develop some specification formalism
where the translation will be greatly
exponential or something this will only
mean
that we are even more abstract
and another thing to my point uh
to keep in mind is that the bound this
double exponential bound it applies
also to the size of the system there are
examples where the smallest correct
transducer
is doubly exponential uh in the
specification
and this suggests that another thing
that we may want to do
in the future is to measure the
complexity of synthesis in terms of the
minimum satisfying transducer
and not in terms of the specification
itself
and then an efficient algorithm
will be one that may be linear yes if it
does not
work more than a the size of the system
which is what we do also in model
checking uh
but now let's move to more current
concerns and this is the fact that still
verification is more uh
appealing to people in practice and
synthesis we
we have some uh some tools and and
a lot of uh advances in recent years but
we don't see it
uh applied in parties uh very
it is not very popular so and i think
that there are two main reasons which i
think are the
two challenges for for synthesis for the
next
years the first is compositionality very
very
important in verification if we have a
system and we want to
uh verify a conjunction of properties
then
of course we can verify them one by one
it satisfies the conjunction if it
satisfies
each of them and this is why
the size of the system is considered the
computational bottleneck
as if the specification is very very
long we can decompose it
and moreover when we say a compositional
it's not only the fact that we can
decompose the specification we can also
decompose
the system there are many algorithms for
modular verification
there is obstruction and abstraction has
a compositional
aspect in it because we can abstract the
system according to the specification
yes different abstractions
according to the different
specifications so
uh the facts and we have
compositionality and verification is
crucial in synthesis
we still don't have the fact we need to
synthesize
a conjunction of requirements it
wouldn't help us to
synthesize systems for each of them
there are lower bounds i mean we know
that it has to do with the blow up
uh in the product of automata but but
still
we are and there it's not that there is
no work about it but
we are still in the very early days of
a really efficient compositional
algorithms for synthesis and such
compositionality
is important in three aspects first it
will make synthesis more
feasible it will make it more usable
because
probably if we are a compositional
then we will have libraries we will have
things that are more oriented to small
specifications that
we can then combine and we will also
know better what we are doing
and that has to do with explainability
also very
important topic and and the fact that
compositionality
is strongly related to these three
issues
the second point that i think is very
crucial is quality
quality quality quality and again our
situation
with respect to verification is much
more challenging for a
very verifier can come to a designer and
say let me help you find bugs in your
design
the designer should be very happy about
it no problem
in synthesis the synthesizer will come
to the designer and ask her to replace
her
the designer is not expected to
cooperate with such a thing
and we can tell the designer okay you
will be able to focus more on what and
less on how
still the designer will say and she is
right
that her designs are better you cannot
automate me there are
still many many issues that have to do
with quality
uh that we are very far from automating
yes when the designer says that
her designs are better we don't even
know exactly what is better
because our specification formalism is
typically
a boolean so all the issue of
quality and how to formalize
quality and how to formalize better we
are starting to work on it
we can talk about behavioral quality how
the specification is satisfied
usually there are many ways to satisfy a
specification
and we want to stay the design to
satisfy them
in the best way and one way to do it is
to move to multi-valued specification
formalisms
and then there is quality of the
implementation how efficient
is the design and efficient has many
aspects
size time electricity consumption money
if we want to add budgets and things
like that
and this is very important and we hardly
touch it in synthetics
think about yeah wait never mind this
in theoretical computer science a there
is a lot of research on design of
efficient algorithms and we know many
short past many max flow algorithms they
are all correct
but still we know some algorithms are
better than others
in our case of synthesis we synthesize a
system
and we hardly refer to many quality
aspects of it so what we need is
appealing synthesis
and i think the important point about it
will
be compositionality and the fact we want
the system
the synthesized systems to be of high
quality
this is it thank you thank you arnold
thank you on time so uh as i mentioned
at the beginning uh if you have
either any questions or just opinions
feel free to
uh write them in the in the q a and the
chat
uh so we'll collect them and we'll
revisit them at the end
um let me now turn it over to uh radu
who's going to introduce our new
our next panelist
i was muted sorry for that okay so it's
uh my my great pleasure to introduce our
next panelist uh
ezio bartocci whom i know for a very
very long time
since i was an uh tenure-track assistant
professor in stony brook and he was a
phd a young
student coming from camarino
to work with us and so we had a long
journey together
and we still have and what the journey
this is uh
it's yesterday a full professor for
formal methods in computers
in cyber physical systems engineering uh
the faculty of computer science
technical university of vienna and he's
leading uh the trust for the
cyber physical systems group of the
cyber physical systems research unit the
primary focus of his research is to
develop formal methods
computational tools and techniques that
support the modeling and the automatic
analysis
of complex computational systems
including software systems cyber
physical systems
and biological systems without further
ado
we don't have time to talk about all the
awards that you've got
so just look at his web page
it's here the floor is yours
thank you for the kind introduction and
thanks for this invitation
so i i'm going to now i have 10 minutes
where i'm going to
try to answer to some of the questions
that
sanji actually posed to me last week
um first of all like starting about
i mean i already wanna introduce what is
this interview so i will not
uh talk more about that but i
will start by by looking at what are the
opportunity
opportunities that we have in the last
decade for synthesis
and i will start by saying that uh
one of the you know incredible
achievement
was uh in 2011
when we have the program when there was
the
program synthetic for by example for
non-net
expert programmers that is implemented
in
the excel program
with the flash field that enables to
understand
i mean to understand the pattern and to
generate
the pattern given the example of the
provided by the user uh then in 2015 we
have the syntax guiding program
synthesis that is the minus one
the last decade for what concerning
synthesis and the idea is to
uh basically guide the the exploration
of the design space using a
syntactic certification
and many many many works
are now based on this method it's called
also
a sigus sigurd method and
another things that it's more close to
my field
is what happened in telling the um
usually
people are talking about uh
deterministic programs i
um i'm working more on probabilistic
programs
and one uh
one opportunity that we have in this
decade was
many tools for automatically synthetize
the parameters
over finite probabilistic models
this is just to give you an example
this is the newt example how to use
uh fair coin to simulate uh
six uh phase die and it's possible to
guide the
uh given uh probabilistic property and
it's possible to guide
the parameter synthesis so how to
synthesize the parameters
on the transcription in order to get the
results
another interesting
result that was done in probabilistic
programs was the
extended the counter example guardian
inductive synthesis before finite
probability programs
and here you can see an example of
program sketch in prisma where you
add the you add the sum all in the in
the program and automatically
uh it's possible to use smt to generate
a program instance
and then we could we can use the
challenge approach in order to
synthesize
the program this is another
opportunity that i see in
in the last years basically together
with our coverage we
develop an automatic uh method
to generate uh moment based in variance
for
polynomial probabilistic programs and so
here the idea is that
your gene the
we can extract automatically some
uh moment some expression symbolic
transform solution for the
for the expected value of the of some
variables of the program
and this can be done also symbolically
it means that we can
use the symbolic the symbols to
basically do synthetic
of parameters or we can even in the
future use the
expected value to constraints the design
[Music]
design space of the projective programs
talking about the progestin methods
these are
these the priority methods in nowadays
played a big role on synthetic and in
particular
not only uh about how to generate
uniform initial candidate for the
for the for the synthesis
and but also how to explore up with the
space of all the possible programs this
is the
uh for example um an important result in
the last decade was this locating super
optimization
or scaling after super optimization that
enabled to
basically find the optimal code in a
large
design space uh so graphic
methods are also used for example in
syntax guiding hinted
to the meta polish asking your address
to
basically decide with which probability
an expression of
a candidate expression for the synthesis
can be
came into another one
another opportunities that i see
recently to use the neural network to do
program synthesis
and this is due to this
paper uh publishing nature differential
neural computer where they show how to
learn how to manipulate the
how to use neural network to learn how
to manipulate
the memory of the memory
complex data structure and this also was
recently used for for performing new
uh neurosymbolic program synthesis um
so what are the uh the problem promises
to
to be uh that are still open and
that we we need to fulfill first of all
the capability and the limited proof
so most of the time the synthesized
program are
small and they are flat so they are not
they don't have complex structural
complete models
and so we need to uh
we need to come up with new methods for
large-scale programs
and this would require more modular
approach like what they're not
what already uh told in the previous
presentation like composition
the other problem that i see is the lack
of interpretability
um the synthetized programs can match
the specification but
sometimes not the real user intention
due to the ambiguity of the
specification
and this is also
the other problem that i see is that the
synthetic general black box probably
we don't know exactly how the
synthetized program has been generated
so we need a new mechanism to unveil the
process of synthetic providing more
interaction
with the with the user and recently
there is a very interesting paper on
computer
computer human computer interaction
conference
key where basically they started by this
problem so for example you want to learn
how to extract
comma separately numbers from a large
text file
and the user provides this example as
you can see
from these examples all the positive
examples they have all nine and eight as
a
last digit uh while the negative example
they don't have so
uh basically the the program synthesized
by this example is like a program that
actually uh capture the fact that the
eight and nine at the end but
they really don't don't capture the what
the user
has in mind and uh so how to solve this
problem is
basically they propose a way to
explore the the the derivation tree of
the
of the syntax
of the synthesize of the synthetizer
and this is it basically my statement
and um so open to the question
thank you very much i think we go now to
the next panelist
so i think i can take over again
um so uh before we
skip to the next panelist um i think it
might be useful
for us to tell the audience what the
talking points were
very briefly uh if you haven't figured
it out already
um so i'll just go through the the list
of the the high level points that we
gave each of the panelists
to address so that the rest of you in
the audience can also think about this
and please uh
voice your opinions at the end so and
the ones that
didn't have a chance yet to to ask
questions so please don't miss your last
opportunity
all right so uh there were five
categories of things we wanted the
panelists to comment on but of course we
were
we the panelists are welcome to talk
about other
other things as well and broadly we
wanted them to comment on the
the challenges and opportunities for the
future of synthesis in the next five
ten years and beyond right so that's one
of the the big questions we had for them
the other one was about explainability
and usability you've seen already a
couple of the panelists talk about that
the third was on algorithms where do we
need the uh
the the most algorithmic advances um
the fourth was what's the role of
probabilistic methods in synthesis
and where can they be most effective and
then the fifth was
we've seen in the last decade a few
synthesis competitions emerge
like the saigas competition and the
reactive synthesis competition and we
we asked the panelists to comment on the
role of those
efforts and and where they see these
leading in the future
so just to give you some context there
i'm sorry we should have said this at
the beginning but i hope now
uh you understand what are the the
points that
we asked the panelists to comment on um
all right
so without further ado let's go to our
uh next panelists
um and it's my great pleasure to
introduce professor hadas chris gazit
um so hadas is a professor at cornell
university
and um hadas's work uh
has really been trailbrazing in the
sense that
for a long time people wrote a lot of
papers on reactive synthesis
and a beautiful theory but it was just
not gaining traction in terms of
practical applications and
hadas is one of those very first people
who
showed that you can apply reactive
synthesis in an effective manner
to the field of robotics and
in doing so she is over the last 15
plus years she has really made formal
methods
a feel that the roboticists know and
appreciate
all the mainstream robotics conferences
have sessions and formal methods
a lot of these are really centered on
synthesis in robotics from
temporal logic and similar formalisms so
you know hadas has really been
the person who's demonstrated that
impact of formal methods
in this very important field of robotics
and more broadly cyber physical systems
so um i'm really pleased to have hadas
join our panel
share with us uh what she thinks about
the the future of synthesis
okay thanks sanji that was extremely
kind
thank you so much uh um like uh uh so
two things before i start uh one shout
out to neil
who who his paper um on jr1 is kind of
the precursor of all this
and his generosity and discussing it
before before even we start thinking
about that in robotics
um okay the other thing is like a true
academic i kind of ignored
the points that uh you asked us to talk
about in the panel
and i'm going to talk not totally ignore
but mostly ignore uh and then
uh talk about a couple of things that i
wanted to bring up
also my slides are are very poor um but
definitely compared to ona
uh and as you okay so let me share it i
just have
just bullet points so so we can focus on
on something um
but yeah so uh as sanjit mentioned i'm
uh very much coming from a perspective
of so i publish in robotics i see myself
right as a
zerobot assist um i love talking to
former methods people
i can kind of speak the language uh to a
point um
and the things i want to talk about
today are the opportunities that i see
in terms of where synthesis falls and
what the strengths are of synthesis
in the context of robotics and i mean
more broadly cyber physical systems but
i think really robotics a little bit
more unique
in that perspective so so yes 100
um uh ona just put in the two
uh kind of the the the composability
which i was gonna go
you know the question of scalability is
a question that you need to kind of
keep thinking about so composability is
definitely uh falls within that
and quality so those two things are are
it was issue it was just wonderful thank
you thank you um
the things i want to talk about in terms
of kind of the way i see
synthesis making impact in robotics is
uh not so much so i view synthesis
as as automated design right so i think
this is this uh
i mean i said congratulations um it's
all different
views of the same problem but i think
about this about
taking you know letting someone who
doesn't know robots
control robots right so that's kind of
the main the main strength of synthesis
um the quality is not there in the sense
of if there's a specific task i need a
specific system to do
synthesis is not the right approach at
this point because of the question of
quality so i just love that owner went
first
um but where it does come into play is
um
because of all the formalisms because of
all of um
the algorithms that are being developed
and this kind of touches on
explainability
uh synthesis really can provide feedback
and feedback to
the user designer note
you know novice roboticists whatever in
a way that other techniques can't
so i think that is something that is
super exciting and super important when
i think when i when i sell robotics to
my
to the robot when i sell synthesis to
the robotics community
feedback is something that i'm
emphasizing more and more as we go
uh and this includes can i synthesize
something that is has that is not
always correct but has some notion of
partial satisfaction of the
specification what does that mean
right what are what are metrics of
partial satisfaction
with respect to the what a part of the
specification
can i put some ordering on the
specification in terms of what i want to
happen because synthesis
specifically ltl synthesis is very worst
case and we don't want we don't
necessarily want that in robotics
counter examples are super useful kind
of really that i think is fairly
mainstream
uh things that have been happening in
the community are um
suggestions for specification rewriting
so i can't do this
but if you add this assumption now i can
do that or if you if you add
this constraint i can do that right so
um i think that's a direction that
the more tools we have that are
fundamentally built to provide feedback
the easier it is to incorporate these
datas to work with
um changes to the abstraction so i have
we have building blocks we have
propositions they relate to something
physical
and if you think about in robotics
either sensor information or
some actuation can i
uh can i infer anything and infer not in
the sense of machine learning but can i
understand something about my problem
about the building blocks that i'm using
to create this robotic system using the
specification
if i cannot do something is it because
the abstraction i'm using is not quite
good enough
is that the constraints that come from
the abstraction from the way i'm
breaking up this continuous space into
pieces um not allowing me to provide
guarantees
maybe i need to change the abstraction
so those are kind of questions that
come more from the grounding of the
specification language
into the domain um and then online
repair
so you know i synthesize something
scalability you know compositionality
will hopefully help with scalability
um but you know i synthesized something
and i made some assumptions that
assumptions fail
now i need to start doing things online
this is a physical system
moving in the world i could stop we you
know rewrite the specification we
synthesize
that's probably not the best technique
so if there are ways to patch or ways to
repair locally or
what does that even mean those are kind
of things that could be very useful for
physical systems the other thing i
wanted to mention
and this is uh um uh my my
um i lost the word uh it doesn't matter
um
the other thing i wanted to mention was
something that i'm pretty excited about
lately
and and uh as sanjit said i mean we do
have
now uh keywords and robotics conferences
called formal methods for robotics
and uh what we've been starting to
discuss in the last few years
is what does it mean to do synthesis and
verification for human robot interaction
so now we have a system that's composed
of a robot something we control
something that's made of whatever
materials
and we have some understanding of the
sensing something is not great but
we understand it but that we want this
robot to interact with a person
and you can think about treating the
human as a dynamic obstacle
but that does not create interaction
that creates maybe safety
so maybe avoid you know running into
someone
but that's not what i want to do so um
a couple two years ago so february 2019
we had an induction seminar
uh on formalizing and guaranteeing uh
human robin interaction so several
people
were on the call were there and um
the things that came up from that is
that
we need people both from formal methods
and
from hri and from robotics kind of more
algorithmic side of robotics to sit down
and talk together because there's a
bunch of challenges that can't be solved
by one of these
these communities so people are
um or interaction
really is is a new thing is it something
that
uh we don't quite have the right models
we definitely don't have the right
specifications yet
and they're the the specific challenges
um let me let me talk a little bit about
the specific challenges but really this
is
this is my shameless plug of putting uh
a paper that's gonna appear and
communications acm
next i think next edition um
and the idea is kind of what are formal
specifications for human robot
interaction and i'm emphasizing the
interaction
and the best example i can give there's
a bunch of them but the best example i
can give
is imagine a robot doing um assisting in
physical therapy
so in a therapy in in therapy right so
physical therapy there's a physical
therapist there's a robot there's a
patient
and one of the things that are very
important in physical therapy
is to assist but not over assist
so you don't want to uh the robot to
help the person too much because the
person has to learn now the question is
how do i specify that
what is the right set of what are what
is the abstraction that i'm going to
use on this don't over assist and those
are things that have to be
defined and decided incredible in
collaboration with the experts the the
physical therapists
the um the people who are doing hri that
are working with a physical therapist
and and
figuring out the right formalisms that
can both be synthesized so i can
actually get a system out of that or a
controller in this case
but also um
capture some properties of people in a
way that's still tractable same thing i
can say about adaptation so it's very
well known that
people adapt to technology and
technology should be adapted to people
but the adaptation of people to
technology is
very it happens on multiple time scales
so it could be short term someone's just
got really tired and
needs more help or long term you know
abilities change over time
especially if you think about this in
context of therapy and assistive
technologies and how do we create the
models
that allow the specifications that allow
us to capture that adaptivity at
different time skills
so that's kind of the different time
skills kind of one of the most important
thing
the third part and this is again these
are questions not just for you
this is questions for for uh the collab
these are questions to
uh promote encourage collaborations with
people who study hri who are experts in
the questions of interaction and the
question of how people think
uh the final part is variability so
people are not the same
robots are the same could be the same
right if i have a backstory here and i
have a baxter
and you know colleagues of my mine have
a baxter at
uh at brown baxter is just a robot the
two two manipulators
um it's the same robot i can run the
same thing here in the same game there
it'll be fine
but people are not right imagine driving
in israel for example versus driving in
i don't know ithaca new york very
different
and you can think about this variability
in terms of uh of
on the personal level and variability
on the um
societal level and group level the
different dynamics that you might you
might be able to see and then the
question again is
what do i need to model what should be
part of the specification
how do i make sure that i can synthesize
for those parts of the specification so
this is a conversation to be had that's
not
just for uh for for the algorithmic
aspect
but it's informed by and has to be
in collaboration with that all right
with that
thank you so much great thank you hadas
um i guess let's move to the next
panelists
and i believe rujika is going to
moderate that
yes uh so everyone uh so far next final
is the sumit govani and i think everyone
uh established some sorts of personal
connection between
a person who introducing and uh speaker
and i think i assume it and i share a
personal connection that
no one can beat and that's actually we
share uh we were
born we shared a birthday so let's see
who can be that
but now jokes aside uh i i
you know like you're always when you
have a chance to do summon as establish
assume it you always have this tendency
to say
next speaker needs no introduction and
i'm pretty sure that they can really say
about sumit to this community uh because
we all we have also seen
uh uh ezio introduced his work as on the
flash field as a seminal work that
actually
introduce synthesis to
uh like open the big door for synthesis
to be applied to industrial software but
you also know that zoom established
over 100 i've seen on his webpage over
125
high quality peer-reviewed papers he
received
robin miller young researcher award in
uh
1914 and uh he also is a
leading very successful pros research
engineering team at microsoft so
as i said like this speaker really needs
no introduction and it is really such a
great pleasure
assuming that you find time in your
business schedule to
give your opinion about synthesis of
this workshop so thank you sumit
we are looking forward to your to hear
your thoughts
can you can you still hear me yes we can
hear you
okay sorry i was having some network
issues but thanks for the
wonderful introduction
[Music]
so i just put you know
a set of slides you know as a session
about
together so are you
able to see my uh my slide deck
yes we can but your voice is breaking up
i'm wondering whether
if you hide all the videos you might get
a little bit more bandwidth for your
voice
and close close running tasks
actually
what did you ask for an option
yes so is there an option to hide others
videos or i can only
hide my own video uh let's see ashley
are you there can we do that
for uh time being all videos are post
sorry can you say that again can you do
what can you just pause all the videos
except for assuming sharing uh the
screen
um so like only his video shows up is
that what you mean yes
oh i see uh yeah we can do that i think
okay yeah
if
okay okay let's try okay so
let's get started here uh so
uh let me actually uh you know bring you
back to uh
the discussion on flash fill you know
that you that you talked about and it
was also mentioned earlier
so one of the very important factors
behind success of flash fill
was to be able to synthesize programs
from as few examples
as possible and in particular
excel team said that you know if you
cannot make simple scenarios
or simple cases work with just one
example
we will not be able to ship flash fill
because people will lose trust in the
system if it comes up with
funny interpretations after one example
then people might not even
get back to using it again
and at the time i thought you know these
people were
exaggerating uh because you know what
difference does it make you know for the
user to maybe provide you know three or
four examples as opposed to having to
write the program
themselves uh but later on i figured out
you know how right you know was the
excel product team in their
insistence because even today when i
look at hell forums
or people who talk about flash fill they
don't know that you can provide you know
more than one
example so for usability purposes and
for creating trust it was extremely
important to be able to synthesize
programs from
one example and now you think about you
know how better can we make
uh make this uh setting and this is the
kind of experience that i had recently
which i wanted to share
with you folks to again uh you know
heavy folks think about the importance
of what i call a specification reduction
right how can you automatically
synthesize this specification
so we were in a recent thing where
we have been applying programming by
example technologies to
extracting data from different kinds of
semi-structured documents
such as web pages so if you see this web
page here
you might want to extract this into a
tabular format and then all that you
need to do
is to give one to two examples of the
various fields that you want to extract
so
let's say if you want to extract the ear
or if you want to extract the name of
the show you just give one to two
examples of all the fields
and when we took this proposal over to
the power query team which is actually
shipping these technologies now
they said oh we don't have time to build
ui so
uh can you do this with zero examples
and initially i thought they were crazy
you know how can you do do
these tasks with zero examples like zero
specification but then
when i thought more about it it actually
made sense
because let's say if you have a log file
or a text file or a json document right
or a pdf document
and if you have to give one to two
examples of the various tens of fields
then actually it can be quite tedious
for the user
even though it will be much better than
writing the parts of themselves but
still you know giving examples will be
tedious in an absolute setting
and as a human being you can kind of
figure out what the
implicit tabular structure is going to
be
and once you think hard about this
problem it turns out that you can
actually synthesize programs
that can extract nice looking tabular
structure out of such documents
with zero examples and
this is the kind of technology that we
are shipping inside
power query now another variant of
uh specification reduction is some work
that we have been doing
in visual studio and we call this moodle
synthesis
where the user provides examples but
they don't get into any mode to give
these examples they are doing these
examples as part of their natural
workflow
so here what you see is happening in the
slide is
the red green edits that you see so the
user wants to convert the red line into
the green line
so these are what we call repetitive
edits they are not exactly the same edit
but similar edits
so once the user does one or two of
these edits we are able to
recommend all the edits that the user
should be doing in the
rest of their file and for
this system to be useful to developers
it is very important that you are able
to understand the examples
in the user's noisy workflow so the user
is not going to get into a mode and say
look you know these are my one example
of these some of my two examples
so this is the setting where the user is
just doing their task manually
just just doing the task and then we
have to understand the knowledge traces
and figure out what are even examples of
what is even the specification in the
noisy trace
that the user has so this notion of uh
modular synthesis and predictive
synthesis
has become quite important in terms of
creating
the right user experiences and they have
inspired
new problem definitions for us in this
category of programming by examples
now the next thing that i wanted to talk
about
was something in the space of
a topic that we have realized 10 years
ago but unfortunately we have not made
much
progress on it and this topic has become
even more
important and this is this is
programming education so first you know
there is increasing realization about
introducing computational thinking in
schools right and maybe i'm touching to
the choir here
and even today unfortunately programming
remains an optional subject at schools
and is not even available at all schools
and this further contributes the
privilege gap
secondly the demand for computing skills
has continued to increase
with more than two-thirds of the tech
jobs present outside the tech sector
and there are many more students who
want to take cs courses
than the current capacity in colleges in
fact 50 to 90 percent employers across
various countries can't even find enough
talent
and this problem will only worsen as ai
displaces mundane jobs
that in industrial information created
and we need to empower people with tools
for creative jobs and programming is an
important part of the toolkit
and finally programming is a very unique
subject you know it's logical like math
creative like arts you know requires
hands-on training like sciences and
there is no unique correct solution to a
problem
it's not easy to check the correctness
of a solution so doing grading and
personalized feedback to students is
very hard and today's programming
toolkit
caters to professional developers and is
very far from the challenges that
learners actually face
and it's not surprising that we see a 80
percent dropout
amongst u.s minorities in introductory
programming classes
so this i think is a great opportunity a
great application area
for program synthesis that i would like
to make a you know plea for here you
know to this
steam crowd and here we need to move
beyond repairs right to hint and
feedback generation and generating the
right conversation with the student
to facilitate learning different
students learn differently and we have
different misconceptions
but we can leverage the past journeys
[Music]
hello
didn't hear your last two sentences so
we did
follow then you could tell that uh
challenges for a new programming
education and about
uh that the 80 percent of minority
students are
dropping out uh so maybe then you could
if you could kind of follow up
uh after this because it was then again
very
like cutted into several steps it was
hard to follow
i think we completely lost uh
sumit
i'm back here for some reason i'm back
now yeah
yeah maybe you could just tell us uh
when you argue
about how eighty percent of students
drop out maybe you could continue from
there because then we kind of was really
cut it and we couldn't hear you properly
for some reason yes
um so are they false also able to see my
slide or probably not or maybe that's
not
no slides but we can just follow if it
will be easy
yes i i think slide this slide is not
important right so uh so
if you look at us minorities if you
focus the statistics on your
us minorities and look at entropy
programming courses there is a 80
percent dropout
okay and today let's say if you are
reading any kind of uh
subject right and if you if you get
stuck there you can ask you know someone
in your family you can ask your
neighbors to actually help but if you're
thinking about programming
the only only thing that is available in
your hands to give you feedback
you know at your fingertips is the
compiler and
how awful are the error messages in
compilers right compilers were never
designed for learners
in fact even if you think about
compilers in terms of giving feedback to
developers they are pathetic
right compilers talk about errors as to
why their internal algorithms failed
they never look at they never try to
understand what is the user trying to do
and provide feedback you know from that
perspective so i think it's a
huge opportunity for us to move beyond
how standard compilers have been
designed in terms of giving feedback to
the user
and and in case of student learning uh
this
needs to be taken you know much more
seriously and to me you know this is the
reason
for this drop out that we see when
people
struggle with trying to learn their you
know hello world program
yes let me actually share an example
here to see if i can help create some
empathy right
so few months ago my second great child
was solving a math problem
find all tuples a b c d such that a b c
d are distinct digits
and a times b equals c times d for
example two times six equals four times
three
so after he exhaustively enumerated also
40 solutions i teased him
do you know a computer could have done
this for you you just have to tell it
what to do
and his eyes lit up and he got inspired
to try out his first computer program
so i pulled up an online python site and
walked him through some simple print
expressions
and then we started writing the loopy
program for the task and he is holding
his breath watching the screen for the
solution to appear
except i have never written a python
program in my life before
but with 20 years of programming i am
confident i can figure it out
with the help of error messages but no
i failed i tried many different syntax
but the error messages remain cryptic
my child finally asks me papa are you
sure you know programming
ultimately i had to look at the
documentation to make it all work
but you know most people would have been
able to figure out my intent from my
imprecisely written program
and if computers can understand such
sloppy programs or pseudo code
it can not only transform programming
education but the same innovations
will help us see the next programming
revolution
right so so this is what i feel like if
we focus on programming education
as a objective in itself
the underlying technologies will lead us
to rethinking about how programming
should have should be done in the first
place in terms of
using natural language as well all
different kinds of multi modalities
even studio board programming and so on
so i'll stop here
and maybe give the floor back to you
thank you very thank you very much sumit
that was very
uh great perspective and very
interesting talk and i guess we would
all agree that uh
that this is direction to go and uh even
on
on the yell this uh the example i can
see that recently we were discussing
that we have this
uh you know like you have intro courses
and the number of uh minority and
unrepresentative students they it
it's large number but the moment when
they come to the defining classes
this number reduces significantly and
that's why the question is like
why maybe why do why do students drop
out
and uh you know like clearly they have
intention to study computer science
but then they just you know like they
don't continue so then that's
really the problem that we try to
address so thank you for your insight so
i'm not giving who is uh cheering our
last uh speaker
uh i am
also i would like to encourage people to
use the q a and ask sumit questions
where he can
answer the remaining one hour that we
have
and last but not least it's my pleasure
to introduce
armando solar lazama who is a professor
at mit
and just a quick introduction armando
introduced uh techniques that i used in
so you could say functional imperative
synthesis of
the non-reactive part of the synthesis
world and then he
he in his dissertation developed
sketches which later evolved
into the psygus specification of
synthesis problems he developed the
counter example
guided inductive synthesis algorithm and
third he showed how to reduce the
synthesis
problem to to sat and he did it on high
performance programming problems
concurrency programming problems
showing the versatility of the approach
later
he was one of the people who kind of
made a bridge between synthesis and
machine learning
in part by working on smooth synthesis
and later he's been using ml to solve
some of the hard
synthesis problems such as what is the
language
in which we synthesize the programs and
also use synthesis to help with
explainability interpretability of
machine learning
and i'll stop here and armando thank you
for finding the time to
joining us we can see your slides so
you have your 10 minutes for you thank
you
awesome thanks a lot and thanks thanks
for the introduction
so i want to talk about two directions
where i think there's a lot of exciting
and promising uh problems and i also
want to
give a little bit of of history of uh
where some of these things are coming
from so
i think two directions that i think are
exciting
i i or i separate them into those
related to
programming and program development
software engineering if you will
and those that are most certainly not
and they're really more about
modeling so software engineering or
our programming tasks were really our
goal
when we started uh working on synthesis
you know
ras is very kind to give me lots of
credit but
you know this was really uh i was
working his group and uh you know got
a lot of my inspiration from uh from him
but uh you know one of our initial goals
was just helping software development
and for the first decade or so of
synthesis research
the the key question was how do we help
people who are trying to write
really tricky low-level code and i would
say you know i can now
say very uh safely that this direction
has proven to be
less promising than we expected there
have been some domains
where the approach is very promising
especially when it comes to dealing with
really
low level you know things like bit
manipulations right if you're the kind
of person
who works on writing really low level
bit manipulations
uh don't write them by hand the saigon
solvers can actually do probably a much
better job than you can
in coming up with this really tricky
intricate
bit level manipulations but i would say
for
other kinds of uh of tasks
the the approach that was originally
embodied by
sketch was a bit unrealistic so believe
it or not
i still do a fair bit of coding myself
it's kind of therapy for me
and several times i've actually had sort
of tricky
programming task where i think you know
if only there was a system where you
could just
leave some holes and write some
assertions and have the system figure
out
details for you you know wouldn't that
be
awesome now i actually have the latest
version of sketch installed and ready to
go
on my machine i know the sketch language
up and upside down i know exactly how to
interpret like even the very obscure
error messages that the sketch
synthesizer
uh gives me and so every now and then i
will actually
dive in and encode the thing that i'm
trying to program
as a sketch and ask the solver to give
it for me
and almost invariably it takes about 10
times
what it would have taken me just to
figure out the code
uh by hand in the first place you know
it's fun
but it's not really that productive and
i would say that
in the area of high performance
computing the area that we were
initially targeting with this kind of
approach i think
the synthesis-based techniques have
largely been surpassed
by approaches based on domain-specific
languages you know things like halide
uh where they're really using more of a
deductive
approach to search for how to transform
the program that you
provided you know that uh has turned out
to work
actually quite uh uh quite well but that
said i think
we've also found a lot of opportunities
for synthesis that i think are very
promising and i think where the
techniques really shine are not where
you're just trying to solve
open-ended one-of-a-kind difficult
algorithm discovery problems
but where instead you're targeting it
for
very specific tasks so for example i'm a
big fan
of the lifting work that alvin chung
and shreve camille have been pushing for
several years now where you're
leveraging synthesis
to take an existing piece of code that
was written as low level
implementation and lifting it to a
higher level representation from which
you can then apply some of these
uh very powerful techniques based on
uh very aggressive manipulation of
domain-specific
uh languages right so this is an
instance where you have to repeatedly
solve
very stylized very focused synthesis
problems where you can afford
to spend a lot of effort
really fine tuning your synthesizer for
this particular class of problems that
you're going to be solving
over and over and over again i think
another space where there's a lot of
promise
for synthesis where again you have this
notion of solving very similar synthesis
problems over and over again and
is broadly in the space of mass
customization
so for example we had a paper a few
years back uh
this was led by my student given uh
she was looking at the problem of
how to generate cnf encoders
for bit vector synthesis right and the
idea was this idea of mass customization
you want to be able to write a custom
bit vector smt solver for whatever
domain you happen to
care about right it turns out that for
different domains
having a different encoder that
has different rules different policies
for how to apply these rules
can actually really make a difference in
terms of being able to solve
the problem very efficiently and it's
the sort of thing where
sure if you
if you are an expert you can do this by
hand and if somebody pays you enough
money
you can sit down and really write a
custom
solver with custom rules custom policies
for this domain but it's much better
if you can have a system where you can
give it a handful
or a little more than a handful of
sample problems and have the system
automatically synthesize these rules
that are actually going to give you a
good synthesizer for this domain more
recently we've been looking
at a domain of database
engines right where if you know that
you're going to be writing
that you're going to be running a
particular set of parameterized queries
on your database and those are really
the only queries that you care about
rather than the one-size-fits-all
database engine could you actually
search and find the
layout or the engine that is actually
going to
exactly have all the data in the place
where it needs to be
where a lot of things are going to be
pre-computed for you
everything is going to be set up so that
things can be
really really fast
also i think when we're talking about
creating software we can't forget
end-user
programming i think as
as more time passes i think it it really
vindicates
uh sumit's original vision of end user
programming
as a really high impact and really
important domain
for the community to uh to focus on
i do think however that there is a big
opportunity now to move beyond the
tyranny
of input output examples and
into richer forms of interaction i think
in particular leveraging
the ability of deep learning to
associate meaning
with very unstructured inputs
right thinks uh there's already a lot of
work going on
with things like natural language but i
think we can do even more
focus for example on things like uh
hand-drawn diagrams or or even looking
at the way
the user has been interacting with their
data up to a certain point and use that
to get
a strong signal about what the user is
trying to do
and how to move from there
the other thrust though that that i
really want to emphasize is this idea
of modeling and i think the roots of
the this our ambition here is really
uh summarized by the title of our recent
expeditions project of
understanding the world through code
and uh this is a pretty uh large-scale
uh
effort with lots and lots of uh
people involved both experts in specific
domains as well
as in synthesis more
generally but the roots of this effort
actually go back to uh to this paper by
uh susmit ja and sumit and sanjit
and ashish tiwari where i think they
were really the first ones to pose this
question of well what if
instead of the classical view of
synthesis of you have a specification
and you're trying to generate an
implementation what if what you have
is this opaque artifact and what you're
really looking for
is a high-level description of what this
artifact is doing right and it turns out
this is useful not just for reverse
engineering
a you know some kind of exploit code
but for lots of other things i think
still the gold standard for this kind of
research
is uh ross's and ali's
effort on reverse engineering uh
and they see elegance uh warm and you
know we've been doing a lot of work
in this space looking at things for like
reverse engineering
code reverse engineering cad models even
reverse engineering
language this was work led by kevin
ellis
but i think there's really big
opportunities here and
we are focusing on a handful of domains
but for all of these domains
the big challenge is really dealing with
real numbers
and dealing with this interaction
between the kind of logic
programming languages based techniques
and deep learning and i think this is
where
there are a lot of untapped
opportunities and unfortunately i am out
of time
but all i want to say is that i think
there is a really big and important
space
in looking at this intersection between
machine learning and ai
and programming languages and formal
methods based techniques and how they
interact with each other
thank you armando wonderful you're on
time and you are inspiring
uh with that i'd like to open the
forum for everybody to ask questions and
i think the best way to do it
would be if people raise hand
or if they don't feel like speaking
use the q a and we can then
sort of read out the questions and
answer them
so do we have a hand from anybody in the
i see sumit's hand up
all right perfect go ahead
so uh i very much agree with
i'm having some eco here
so many if you're using your phone as
well you'll have to mute one of those
yes yes so that was the problem so i i
fixed that
yes i would very much
around using other kinds of signals
besides
examples uh for end user programming
right and maybe even for you know
developer productivity
so this is where i would like to you
know bring this recent
happening thing in machine learning to
this community if you have not paid
attention to this
but the most happening thing in the
machine learning community these days is
what is called
a gigantic pre-trained model so openai
has trained this
model called gpt3 which can
pretty much solve any problem in the
world of course it might not do it very
effectively but you can use it to do
anything
in fact you know someone told me oh it
can also solve flashflow kind of
problems
and indeed it does you know and for one
week i was very scared if i going to
lose my job or what
uh
turns out that it requires it can do
many cases so still probably not there
yet to replace you know a flash fill
but it is incredible as to the wide
variety of tasks it can solve
so many people have been trying to use
it for converting natural language to
code
in different programming languages and
they have very impressive demos that
they put together how robust these
systems are you know so i can tell you
that i think that they're not very
robust and more work needs to be done
but here is the big uh observation that
that i wanted to share
here right that program synthesis is a
very multi-disciplinary field
right if you want to think about
broadening the intended specification to
things like natural language would you
all need to have you know natural
language experts and one of the reasons
why
i failed to make you know much dent in
this area even though i tried over the
last decade
is because i could not really figure out
you know partners in machine learning
and natural language understanding
but you know what gt3 can be your best
friend
right so this huge model that open ai
has released it can be your best friend
and it can avoid the need for having to
train you know large machine learning
models or collect large amounts of data
so
this is something that i would highly
recommend the community to
try and understand its power and see how
it can fill in the gap where you have
wished you know machine learning could
have been useful and see if you can if
you can
you know bring it to you in your second
armada do you care to respond well
i i think i guess i can i can just uh
agree
uh we've actually been playing with uh
some of these pre-trained uh language
models a bit uh both
gpt3 and uh bart
i think a big opportunity there is not
just
in you know there are things that those
models can do but i think we can do
better right when it comes to really you
know putting out the code and making
sure that you're actually getting code
that is right
i think one of the things that it really
valuable to exploit in these models is
the fact
that they have one thing that is really
missing
in a lot of synthesis work and it's more
knowledge of the broader world right and
a lot of programming tasks especially
once you go beyond
uh sort of very simple uh
very well-defined algorithms they really
require
knowing something about the world and
knowing things about the tasks that
you're trying
to to do in order to understand the kind
of shorthand
that for example if somebody says oh i
need here
to uh to calculate all my uh the total
of all my expenses right well
you kind of need to figure out that
they're talking about accounting and
that they're talking about
uh that tells you something about what
the program is supposed to
uh to do right and in a lot of domains
there's a lot of
sort of domain specific vocabulary that
i think if you're able to capture it you
can get a lot of signal about what the
person is actually trying to do
okay anybody else from the panelists
want to respond you could just
raise raise your hand
don't see any then radhu radu's hand is
up
yes so actually i had a question for
sumit so
i was wondering is there any uh
you know example i mean any work on uh
synthesizing
programs from natural language uh
directly i mean
using for example deep learning or
whatever
yes yes rather no there is a um a rich
body of work in this area and most of it
has been around
synthesizing sql queries
and or that kind of you know setting and
the reason is
that these are the places where natural
language is generally a better fit as
opposed to let's say
requiring examples but last has also
explored some work in how examples can
also be used to bring in more trust and
explainability
if you work with natural language
because one challenge with natural
language always is going to be
how do you know that your program is
correct right so with examples also this
is a challenge but at least you know you
have some
way of verifying that the example that
was provided was correct or not
uh and then the other thing about sql
queries is that it is a well-contained
domain as opposed to arbitrary
programming
and the key technical challenge that
people have tried to resolve in this
area
is to develop a better understanding of
the underlying
schema because when you want to say
things very naturally how do you figure
out
as opposed to saying it very robotically
because if you have to write down a
query you don't want to be very
explicitly talking about the very
the column names or the schema this can
be naturally inferred from the natural
language this would be cool and this is
one of the big challenges that i feel
the community has resolved successfully
and now the challenge would be how do
you move beyond the domain of sql
queries and more for end user
programming as edmund was
talking about all right thanks a lot
thank you uh suguman your hand is up
hi can you hear me yes
all right thank you all panelists for
your wonderful
uh for your wonderful insights on what
lies what the future of program
synthesis and reactive synthesis is
so my question is mostly for the reactor
synthesis community
and well so like as hadas mentioned that
we are using reactor synthesis now to
design controllers for complex systems
like robotics or even
cps systems but the truth remains that
reactive synthesis assumes a lot of
uh assumes that the state space is
finite or the actions are finite
or that the agents play synchronously in
a certain way
which which may be unrealistic for what
these real-life scenarios are
and on the other hand there are
learning-based approaches like
reinforcement learning
which make none of these assumptions
however those give absolutely no
guarantees on the
functionality of what policy they learn
or what control they learn
so my question really is how do you see
both of these worlds
the world of reactor synthesis which
makes strong assumptions but gives very
strong formal guarantees
combined with the world of reinforcement
learning which manages to learn
controllers
without assumptions but may have very
very weak guarantees
who wants to take up the question hadas
seems ready
yeah i think um so thanks for that
question i think
um let me i i think i disagree with some
of your premises there
in the sense that um reinforcement
learning doesn't require
any structure i don't think that's true
definitely not for robotics a lot of the
things that are happening you know
you need a lot of structure to uh start
the problem i mean what is the reward
function
what is your set of actions that
requires a lot of structure
um on the other hand synthesis uh
so let me rephrase by structure i
possibly just meant the difference
between
finite domains and continuous domains
well there i also
slightly disagree with you in the sense
that i don't know if disagree is the
right word but
um synthesis is done over an abstraction
and that abstraction can
can uh be grounded in a continuous space
right so it is you know if you think
about reactive synthesis for robots
you you can still think about um you
know areas in space and that would be
your discrete abstraction and then any
controller that drives you
you know the the grounding of the
symbolic to the physical how do you go
from
the symbol transition into this physical
transition that's where you kind of
expand back into
into physical world so there's still
going to be so 100 agree with you about
the abstraction
but that abstraction also exists in
reinforcement learning because you still
need the set of actions you still need
to have that uh
that kind of uh so i think the distance
between those two
um approaches isn't actually not that
stark in terms of of uh the way i'm
thinking about it
but to your point i mean i mean
enforcement learning requires less uh um
well arguably the reward function uh how
you you
how do you decide on the reward function
is kind of how you decide on a
specification
right there's there's that kind of um
match and and again slightly tangential
to what you what you would you
how you post the question i think
there's a really strong
uh connection between them right so you
know there's a lot there's a bunch of
work on
reinforcement learning with temporal
logic constraints there's a work on
using
reinforcement learning within the
context of synthesis right or learning
in general right so
there's the boundaries are are um
uh we're hazy right yeah yeah um
yeah i guess that i wanted to kind of uh
rephrase that in the sense that i think
they're both uh
they both have more restrictions than we
think
uh or when we actually try to implement
those things
maybe the question is not that the
boundaries are blurring what
what is the kind of guarantees we're
looking for i see
maybe that is the question like should
we so safety is something that
reinforcement learning can do
right and a functional guarantee
something that reactive synthesis can do
because we have temporal logics to guide
to guide the search so what kind of
guarantees are we looking for
is it somewhere in between or what what
is it
that is very domain specific i think in
my mind anyway so i think
uh just safety is not enough for sure
and and suguman if i can just add one
more thing
on the discrete versus continuous
there's been a quite a bit of work in
the last five
five to ten years on reactive synthesis
for
metric tempo logic signal tempo logic uh
specifications
by blending techniques from control
theory like optimization based
approaches
with logic based specifications so
there's so you know
i think the the field of reactive
synthesis at least for cps and robotics
has broadened
beyond just uh going from ltl i see
so if i may also bring by two cents here
so i think the question is which
optimizer do you want to use
do you want to use a discrete
optimization tool or do you want to use
a
continuous optimization tool and it's
really i see them as complementary
you know sometimes you want to be on
it's always like if you are more on the
planning level on a higher level you
you prefer a discrete optimization tool
you know for example past planning and
if you are on the nasty level uh close
to the earth down
very down to the earth you might you
might want to use a
continuous optimization tool and but you
can switch between them
you know so there is uh you can go back
and forth you know
so i i mean at the end you can have
guarantees with both you know uh but uh
obviously it's easier to provide logical
guarantees in
the discrete world and to provide some
kind of stochastic guarantees on the
on the continuous work
there was a question from edward kim for
hadas
um and i'm not sure that's been answered
um so so promoted
to panelists so he did okay oh great hi
uh
thank you um yeah i was just referring
to
i think it was you who mentioned about
possibility of connecting program repair
to
uh in robotics for uh a patching
online um if i'm not mistaken i'm just
wondering
you know whether there has been any uh
relevant work in in that connection uh
in the
field of program synthesis or repair
maybe that
can be applied but as you see this uh
your robotics
interacting with the environment and
then you realize something's wrong and
then you want to patch that
i'm thinking from that perspective so so
there's
a i think there's more there's a few
things that happen in more
controls in robotics community as
opposed from the formal method from the
programming languages all these
so i'm sure there's work being done in
in you know the
pl people in the room can probably uh be
give you more information on that
perspective i just don't know but from
the
from the controls and robotics there's
some work by richard murray's uh
group that they were kind of
synthesizing small patches
uh i mean i guess small as maybe not the
right word
but um uh an assumption was broken can
you synthesize kind of just a
stop gap kind of uh uh
controller that will bridge you beyond
this assumption failure
there's uh some more actually from my
group that we looked at what happens if
your assumptions fail as you're
executing
how do you want to deal with that can
you rewrite specifications as you go
so it's not so much patching the program
as it is well actually for richard's
stuff he has a dispatching program so
um i'm blanking on the student's name
scott um oh my gosh sorry
this this year i'm losing names like
crazy um okay yeah
yeah okay got it well come to me in a
second but yes but but from the yale
perspective i just don't know
okay thank you so i guess i guess ezio
could
uh jump in uh in patching the repair
if you want to see something
it's you sorry it was muted uh
yeah so we so there are many
so if we have for example um
so we developed a method to
um to localize
a port when it happens so basically you
have like a cpf you have
that could be a robot whatever right and
you have like a spec
uh in singapore logical metric internal
temporal logic and you want to
um figure out like uh you want to
when when the spec is violated that you
want to
understand what is the responsible
component
and the responsible moment in which the
violation happens and this could be used
for example to disable the component
and substitute the component with
another one
that is equivalent um
i don't know i mean this could be this
is another thing that
can can be done for example using
uh foreign terms of stochastic system
and there is
a lot of work about repairing the model
so
if you have a stochastic model that does
not satisfy properly
you want to find the minimal change
of parameters that the system
will satisfy the property so on that
there is a lot of work
uh also there is a tool called property
that
is used on the
thank you so there's a question in the q
a
let me read that out so this is from
sebastian jungas and
the question is is there a good
interpretation of programming by example
in cyber physical systems with noisy
sensors
partial observability and others the
notion of a single input output trace
does not seem to be super informative
does smooth synthesis
solve this problem and how can reactive
synthesis play a role in this
so uh please go ahead yeah
i mean i would say that for now this is
a very
good question it's very interesting um
what i would say that
there is no direct way to do yet but
what
what what is now coming out is
for example uh learning specification
from data
so there is a lot of work i think what's
assumptions
about something like based on data how
to get
what is the stack that satisfy the data
so synthetizing uh
ntl formulas or synthetizing api on the
data
and then from that one could use this
spec to
basically try to synthesize the
the model so i would say that this could
be like
one approach thank you i think uh sumit
do you have a response as well yes so
one insight i would like to add
is that the reason why flash flight
systems are able to learn from
one example in many simple cases
is not because there is a
ground truth right so for example let's
say i want to convert
sanjits asia into sesia extract the
second word one program might be expect
the last word one program might be take
everything after the first space
there are millions of interpretations
all of which are going to be correct
if the inputs consist of two words and
in that case it doesn't really matter
which one you pick so the question is of
the
trillions of interpretations in the
underlying domain-specific language
can you find one in a million which is
going to be correct and that is the big
observation that we use so in other
words
there is a implicit structure on the
data
because of which many programs become
equivalent and
as long as you can find any one of those
programs
the job is done so that is one setting
where you can learn from
very few examples the other thing is to
understand the kinds of biases that you
will have in your system
or in your domain that you can that you
can leverage or exploit
right so because if you look at the
cloud the most classical work in this
space of synthesis is that of synthesis
of regular expressions
in my mind you know that's one of the
first pieces of work that was that had
quite a bit of you know elegance to it
and you see how many examples are
required to learn regular expressions
you know often several tens or even
hundreds
and how on earth can we learn flashflow
programs from just one example and flash
two programs are way more complicated
than regular expressions
it is because we are not aiming for a
very specific ground truth all we care
about is getting the task done
and one of many as long as you can
synthesize one of many you know
it it is a deal there
thank you so much personally i think
also
the bayesian view can be very useful in
in that context right where you can view
this really as
well i have a prior uh belief about
the the space of tasks that uh that
people actually care about right and i'm
trying to update that prior
based on these potentially noisy inputs
and these noisy observations and i want
to
also further update it based on uh
you know any additional hint that that
is being provided
uh by me and i do think that this is a
gap in some of the more formal methods
driven techniques is
uh being able to uh
to incorporate i i know there are uh
techniques to
uh to do this but i think this is a
space where
potentially additional research could uh
allow you to do things even more
efficiently
okay i think hadas raised hand as well
yeah just kind of
addressing the first part of the
question the is there a kind of
equivalent for
programming from example so there's a in
in robotics in general there's um
learning from demonstration which is a
very kind of established community that
uh that looks at at very
a limited number of executions sometimes
if it's an arm it could be you know you
either literally push it or
move it the way you want or you tell
operate it or whatever and then you
learn from that controllers that are
more generalizable
and and ideally this will be invested
work on
on taking those learning from
demonstration controllers and composing
them
and there's kind of now work for
learning from demonstration but then
learning the specification from those
demonstrations so there's
a bunch of work going on in that
community um
in terms of in terms of robotics or you
know cyber physical systems and all
okay great um i have a question of my
own and this is
more on the reactive synthesis side um
and
perhaps directed towards hadas first
um oh wait i see ordna raised hand
let me make sure or not or not do you
have a response as well
to the previous question but it's
something small again about this
by example that there is talk
about a ranking
a different possible systems
because we talked about quality so if
you have several possibilities
to satisfy so the examples they all
satisfy the specification
but you let the user rank them and their
synthesizer tries to to learn what is a
good and what is the bed and add
multi-valued
features to the specifications okay
thank you
all right let me resume my question so
my question is about really in
reactive synthesis in applications to
domain like robotics
uh after all these years do we
understand
how effective logic and temporal logic
in particular is in specifying tasks
where is it useful and where are other
ways of specifying tasks
better
that's a question sanjit um
i'm a i find myself it's a little bit
difficult for me to answer this because
the reason for that is robotics and kind
of on the commercial side
is very much task oriented right i want
a roomba to clean my floor
fine i want uh uh you know
amazon to to or whatever
dynamics now picking up uh parcels all
that so robotics in kind of in a
kind of industrial perspective is very
very task oriented where synthesis does
not quite make sense yet again
going back to our onus point about
quality
so the question is is temporal objects
enough is it it's clear that ltl is
probably not enough
because we want timing because we want
we care about distances we care about
robustness
so i think paulo gave a talk right in
this
series um things like stl have this
robust semantics that help kind of i
don't want to be i mean
i guess from ltl if as long as i am i'm
this far away from a corner
i'm correct but you know there's
uncertainty and i'm going to probably
crash into that corner so
so i want to have to have robustness so
in terms of tasks that
um it provides a richness that is that
is interesting and the fact that the
community is kind of looking more into
it
um broadly speaking and also kind of
that
touches on the planning community and
there's a bunch of kind of connections
there
whether it's enough or we know that it's
going to be that i don't know how to
answer yet
yeah i mean my question is not so much
about it whether it's enough
but more about uh our understanding of
where to use logic and where to use cost
functions
and where to maybe use demonstrations
like i mean i think there's a general
understanding that we want to do
multi-modal specification but
uh but specifically in reactive
synthesis it's i don't feel like there's
an
understanding that's emerging of how to
how to play with these different
ways of doing specification and i think
also it's more than that right it's it's
also
how do you play with a different level
of abstraction what do you use for which
level right if i need a controller that
can pick something up
i probably don't want to use synthesis
for that i have so many
wonderful learning based controllers
even model based that i don't really
need to do
any synthesis per se as we were just
describing it here so
the question is what should be used at
which level and i think the
the my perspective and people disagree
with me for sure
is that ml makes more sense for for kind
of creating
the abstraction for creating the pieces
that you can compose and then the logic
and the
formal methods and all these things are
more towards the higher
level of higher level abstractions more
complex specifications compositions and
all these things
but you know there's some people who are
very much you know pixels to to
whatever to to
but i can also say something on this
topic maybe last you want to go first
i wanted to switch to a somewhat uh
different topic not really different but
i'll go after you
so uh to provide maybe a little bit of
an abstract
answer to sanji's question about this
multi modality and when to use what
so one thing that i have found extremely
useful in my research
is to deeply understand the current user
experience
and then to design ai technologies
around that and i will say that this is
a great opportunity
for us to think about partnering with
our
family
you know usually do is you know
problems identify top columns you know
do user studies and so on and
ai community is more about
and there's a rich opportunity for us to
in my experience in terms of practical
the lot of technologies with the right
user experience has been extremely
important there is no other way that we
will be able to get these technologies
in their hands
all right thank you so much i think it
broke up a bit but i think the gist of
it is to do
more user studies and engage with hci
um thank you um
raz i think we can switch over to your
topic now
yeah i want to start by endorsing that
that position that more hci is
extremely important and understanding uh
what the user wants and what is it that
we can compute and tell the user
is important but but the question i want
to ask follows up on armando's point
that
domain specificity is the way to to
success
of synthesis and and i really want to
ask two questions one of them is
you know yes it's been observed that you
need to work in a domain to make
synthesis scalable understandable and
make it easy to build synthesizers and
in fact you could say that
reactive synthesis is an example of such
a domain where we had dsls for
specifications like ltl
and dsls for implementations like
transducers
and in fact the entire community grew
around this domain and these dsls
and the paper that just uh orna
linked in the chat is sort of an
example of a step towards well could
there be a higher level dsl
in uh reactive synthesis right this is
sort of a
problem of paper on synthesizing
uh programs from components but still
using the same
dsl for the specification ltl but now
the implementation has
components so my question for the
reactive synthesis people
what is this understanding
that that is forming about what should
be the higher level dsls
or levels of abstractions if you will
maybe task specific
maybe those that would enable better
modularization
um curious what's the state there
so i i can say something
and this goes back already to work from
the 90s so i think that
already then rajivalu and tom heinzenger
wanted to to develop they called it a
interface automata well where the goal
is really to hide everything in between
and replace the transducers themselves
by
their interface now there is still a
good question what an
interface is yes whether but it was some
assumptions and guarantees on the
interface themselves
and then anyone can fit in anything
wanted so so the paper was a
it was interface automata and then other
interface modules or something like that
but but the idea which makes a lot of
sense
is really to focus on the interfaces
among the components
thank you
okay um
so i want to actually raise a point that
i don't believe we have
uh addressed yet which is the role of
the competitions
we've had uh several years now of the
syntax guided synthesis competition
uh with multiple tracks including
programming by example and invariant
synthesis
we've also had several years of the
reactive synthesis competitions
um and i know there are several people
here on the
on the call today who have uh either
organized or participated in these so i
just would like to elicit
uh comments from from
panelists and audience on how do you see
the impact of these competitions and
where do you think
they have fallen short what what needs
to be done to
to improve the impact to broaden them
into
other domains and so forth
[Music]
so i can say a little bit about that um
i think for the domains where
the the competition has focused there
has been you know really impressive
progress right especially uh if you
compare
the solvers from year one with the
the the soldiers on year four and their
performance on
uh on this uh benchmarks it's
uh you know for example for some of
these bit manipulation domains
the the difference is really uh striking
and i think that's what competitions do
best really focus
on a narrow
computational problem and and really
push to
uh to get that to be really good
i think if we view the future as being
not just about the individual core
engines but also about
uh more of the infrastructure around
them and more of how do we fit them
together how do we
customize them to uh
work well for bigger more challenging
problems i think that suggests maybe a
different format
of competition and i think unfortunately
it's one that is
harder to to pull off where you're
testing not just
on performance on a particular problem
or a particular class of problems but
also
versatility and and how easy and how
well it adapts to
to different uh domains uh
i don't unfortunately know exactly how
you would uh
test for that in in a systematic way
that works
year to year
i i could add to it i probably will say
the same thing in different words is
that
in my experience in building synthesis
systems the algorithms was rarely the
limiting
factor it was often what armando
described as taking 10x longer than
solving the problem which was
essentially designing the dsl for the
domain its semantics and then
designing often some abstract semantics
which you can then use for things like
pruning
or in essentially that in the user
facing synthesis problems it's more
about what is the user interaction the
sort of stuff that
sumit talked about and the synthesis
competition does not quite emphasize
innovation in that domain because it
sort of uh the specification includes
the description of that
language and its semantics and it
doesn't let you define
abstract semantics to sort of improve a
better algorithm
so i am totally with
armando how this could be graded it
would need to be more of a
perhaps of a beauty contest where you
describe a challenge and people need to
solve it
and you would need to then measure more
of a
how much human effort went into
designing the system what problems it
can solve
it would need to be more judged by a
jury rather than
by just running the programs i think
yeah that's a good point and perhaps it
also points to the fact that it
one competition can't solve everything
right so perhaps this is a place where
one can engage with the hci community
and develop
something that that they could bring
their expertise to
other responses
okay if not there's another question in
the chat from
edward kim uh edward do you want to read
that out
oh yeah um this is a general question to
all the panelists about synthesizing
probabilistic program synthesis
which hasn't been touched upon because
it's uh
it's a problem on its own but
just in general what aspects or
techniques from program synthesis
can be useful for probabilistic program
synthesis
um and and i'm just wondering uh
also from the application side the fact
that program can capture
probabilistic aspects or some
stochasticity
in the world can be useful i'm just
wondering
uh is there any applications or exciting
fields where
probabilistic program synthesis can also
be useful or
gain a lot of traction
i may try to answer actually my my talk
i
uh i thought i touched this aspect about
probabilistic programs
there are many techniques
that are used i mean that are born
from uh from program synthesis for
example
there is uh the work of just peter
katowin and
cheska and the sebastian young that
that uses that attended
the service loop to synthesize
prism models
that satisfy certain properties there is
a lot of work also
on using i mean try to figure out not
only transition but
about parameters and recently
[Music]
to specify components so the idea is
that you have like
you have a first program and
and you have like uh ndps with the
multiple transitions
and you want to find what what is the
right schedule as such that the
probability behavior of the step
is equivalent to the to the one uh to
i mean the probability behavior of the
mdp is equivalent to the
uh to the spec so you can see this
actually the probabilistic output
property
because you want to say that for all the
schedules that can
attach that the ndp uh
vassas
[Music]
concerning the other question about
examples i mean
all the i mean prohibited programs are
used
in many different
domains from security for example
differential privacy
all privacy related issues
and also
optimization algorithms for example and
used probably method so there are many
uh
even distributed content for example so
there are
work to try to synthesize what are the
uh progressive parameters such that they
have the
self stabilization algorithm proposed by
airman's
converge as fast as possible
so there are many many of these examples
i don't know whether i answered all the
questions
you have i think
she had her hand up as well
sorry you're muted or not
yeah i said that once as you mentioned
mdps
then uh my it included my
response okay thank you roz
i'd like to ask a question for orna i
really like the framework within which
you compared verification
and synthesis and uh as well as the two
challenges that you
post compositionality and and quality
so one question is sort of uh
just clarification can you tell us more
about what are the quality problems and
the second
bigger maybe more open-ended question is
could we extend your framework
to think of synthesis verification is a
continuum where in
synthesis the way you described we only
give the specification
the property in verification we give
everything right an implementation as
well as the property
is there something in the middle where
for example we achieve compositionality
of synthesis by giving the decomposition
of the system or part of it
something that is present in the
verification case
do you have any thoughts on on that um
so i will start with the second when you
ask the question i thought i will start
with the first
but i think that control
may be something in between because in
control
we do have and repair is also
related to control yes because we have
some some skeleton
uh and we just need to direct the
the skeleton a bit more in order to
fulfill the goal so so con and in
control we can
uh start with the system that is a
modular and have everything and only add
some
unspecified components uh
so i think that control may be a
a good opportunity the the problematic
thing is that
all the lower bounds we have on
synthesis apply also to control because
the special case of a system that is
really underspecified
is also there uh so that's
that's one thing but it's an interesting
question i will be happy to hear
more people about it now about quality i
will be happy to talk because that's the
thing i'm
studying in the last a few years
and everything starts with the fact that
our specification formalism is boolean
so if i say every request is eventually
granted i can give you
10 ways of satisfying it they will all
be correct even though i don't know they
give multiple grants to
to request or wait a lot of time
so a first step is the development
of a multi-valued specification
formalism
we extend ltl to a logic that gives
values between zero to one this already
exists
and using this logic you can prioritize
events or an example in the context of
synthesis if we have
a specification like an assumption
implies a guarantee
then a possible way to satisfy this
specification
is to make the assumption false
so in our framework you can just give a
lower grade to systems that behave like
that
so we have quality we call them quality
modalities
and they can also refer to uh waiting
to discount the value if you have long
delays
and things like that and then there are
many algorithms
so now since this doesn't become a
decision problem it becomes an
optimization problem
because you want to synthesize the best
transducer the best system and again
there are many ways to to define it
whether
you check the behavior against the most
challenging
environment or whether you take a
stochastic approach
and you want to know what the expected
truth value is
so there is already a lot of work and
that's
only for behavioral quality
then there is the issue of
implementation quality the size of the
transducer the number of sensors
uh all kinds of things we can budget
and here many questions boil down
to mean payoff games because you
you give rewards and uh and costs to all
kinds of events
so so this is the theoretical frameworks
it already exists there there's still
many issues to but we are
on our way to it thank you so much so
what
what about structure and
compositionality because that's
something you
you were mentioning as important so
how do you bring that in in the
synthesis
so i didn't understand the question
structure what about compositionality
and explainability how do you bring it
in yeah yes
that's a very important challenge
that's homework i think that's homework
for everybody
okay i think that the couple of
questions in the q a uh let me read out
the first one this is from
n sri the question is
i have a question about synthesis in the
presence of multiple levels of
abstraction
in our work we have multiple levels of
abstraction starting from very high
level requirements
and going all the way down to a hardware
description language
some questions about how synthesis would
address this
so any any work that the panelists know
of synthesis at multiple levels of
abstraction
i think this partly goes back to uh you
know the question that we're talking
about earlier in the
about the competitions right which is
that i think a lot of the work in the
community has focused
on the specific search algorithms and
not so much
on the question of how to compose a
an overall development model around
these uh these techniques i think
within i think there is some work
looking at
uh for example combinations of deductive
and inductive
techniques so that you can apply
deductive techniques to break up
the the problem into smaller more
tractable synthesis problems that you
can then reassemble
into a larger solution so i think that's
one way of dealing with uh
multiple levels of abstraction but i i
think it doesn't quite
capture the kind of development that
that i think this question
uh implies where maybe first you figure
out sort of things at a python level and
then you figure out
things at an assembly level and maybe
even then you figure
things out at a hardware level i think
this is something that
the verification community especially
the community around
[ __ ] has put a lot more attention
uh into and sort of building these
stacks all the way down to
to the hardware and i think this there's
really a lot of scope for
synthesis work to to look in that
direction
thank you roz i i want to add
a little bit to this question i don't
think there is
much work in this space one of my
students manko worked on a system that
did
do synthesis at multiple levels it was
essentially a
compiler where you could say you first
partition the program into pieces then
you map those pieces onto parallel cores
then you figure out the communication
between them and then you generate the
assembly code and so these were all
different levels of abstraction
and they were done in sequence i mean in
principle you could
form formulated i guess as one joined
synthesis problem but that would be
beyond the scalability of the system
what we did was essentially backtracking
if you made a bad decision at the
higher level of abstraction then you
could not compile it
because it was the program was bigger
than the hardware you had to backtrack
and try again
so that's essentially all i know um
i i know there sort of a domain where
this
multi-level abstraction problem came up
was something that armando talked about
in terms of modeling natural phenomena
in in biology this shows up very often
where
you may want to synthesize sort of a
model of
of of proteins and at the higher level
you may want to synthesize
some other behavior and these things are
connected the way
programs are built out of libraries out
of smaller libraries
but i'm not sure that has been solved
some machine learning people
mean sort of data-driven approaches have
this multi-modal in systems biology but
not
classical synthesis as far as i know
i just wanted to add to my kind of
clarify my question a little bit as well
um i think i like i like me i like the
answers
um uh so one of the i think the
challenge that we face here
is and maybe my question for the
panelists then is
um you know given that you have we have
these multiple levels of abstraction
and and and you know um starting from
from a very high level and then through
these levels of abstraction sometimes
we refine the abstraction so we'll add
you know um uh for example
we'll add more details about what
constitutes a piece of information
or we add timing details um
then we'll add you know perhaps circuit
details and so we're going
we're kind of refining this thing as we
go along until you get to the point
where you're close to
some kind of a hardware description
language like very well um
so uh and then of course at all these
levels we want to maintain
correctness um and
so i think my question then is you know
those there was talk of dsls
does it make sense to have one wide
spectrum dsl
for all this or do you have multiple
dsls and then how do you connect the
synthesis between those levels um
and then i guess yeah in general yeah i
i just had some questions or i wanted to
see more discussion about how these
multiple levels of refinement handled
but i think you know amanda armando and
yourself
already talked to that point so maybe we
could talk a little bit about the dsl
i think smith raised his hand as well
sumit
yes so um so one place where we
feel the need for multiple dss is when
we start
thinking about going from task
completion
for the user to generating readable
programs that they can then incorporate
in their workflows so let's take the
example of flash fill right
so flash will finishes the task for the
user which is to transform some hundred
or thousand
strings that they might have you know in
excel and the user can quickly
eyebrows the correctness of the result
if something is not correct they can
give one more example and be done
but the underlying program which is in a
domain-specific language is never
exposed to the user
but now if you think about incorporating
these flash flow programs inside users
workflows such as you know data
engineers workflow who might be creating
a python script or might be
writing a c program then we have to
translate
these programs these programs in this
online domain-specific language
to programs in python and c-sharp
now if we do a syntax directory
translation it would be ugly it will
produce code that no one would probably
want to
want to have uh and this is one place
where
there's an importance of designing these
uh different dsl so one dsl within
python one dslr within c sharp you know
one dsl which is an abstract flash field
sl
and to be able to go between these uh
and and one architecture that may be
interesting here
is to first synthesize the program in an
underlying you know common dsl which is
the flashfield dsl
and from there uh go to uh different dsl
so this is one approach and the benefit
of this approach is
that capturing the user's intent is very
hard it requires sophisticated ranking
techniques you need to be able to learn
from one example in most cases and all
of this hard work has been done for one
dsl
and once you have captured the user's
intent then you can use this program
that you
synthesize in this dna
multiple examples
and now we have a task of synthesizing
another dsl
and the advantage is that
you just need a method that can take a
complete specification and generate a
program in the other dsl so that's one
place where i have come across
having to deal with multiple dsls and
just to summarize it is the case of
having to generate readable programs in
a target language or user's choice right
the user might even in fact be using
certain kinds of libraries and they
would like the code to be generated
using those libraries or the user has
certain kinds of
stylistic patterns and we would like to
generate the code using those stylistic
patterns right so huge opportunities in
this space even for the same domain of
let's say
the other place where i figured out
multiple abstractions to be handy is
is having a conversation with the user
to give them what they want so let's say
the user wants to do some kind of
charting so they have some tabular data
and they say oh i would like to plot
your x against y so you give them you
know some code maybe let's say
matplotlib
that can do this kind of uh charting but
then the user would want to say oh
i want this thing to be red right so now
the user has a chart
it is not exactly what they want maybe
they didn't even know what they want
when they start with and now they would
like to interact with the system
and this is another place where you
might have to go between different
levels of abstraction so the initial
level of abstraction is
uh is is more broad and the
second level of abstraction is these all
these fine
details it's about what the labels on
the access could be and
so forth so interactivity is under the
different dslr
i lost the last bit of what you said
there
the second one is along with the user
um i guess sumit if
we couldn't hear the last bit of your
answer but perhaps you could just type
it in the chat
all right thank you um i think we are
past 10 30 pacific
and so that's the official uh end of
today's session and uh this uh
workshop um i want to thank you all for
participating
today's session was absolutely fabulous
lots of discussion lots of interesting
points coming up
thank you to all the panelists for your
uh really insightful and inspiring
uh statements and contributions to this
foot today's session
um and i uh would like to thank everyone
who participated
in this workshop in all the sessions
that we've had throughout the semester
um i think it's if you go back and look
at the the videos posted online it's
it's really a wonderful sequence of
contributions that we've had
and i also want to thank all my fellow
co-organizers
raj radu and particularly rujitsa who is
really the the leader of this whole
organization effort
so thank you all um yeah thank you very
much and
you deserve our applause thanks to all
participants
thank you thank you all for joining us
today in the previous weeks
thank you all bye yeah thanks everyone
this was great
yeah okay look forward to seeing you all
in person
in more normal times yes normal
normal well
fm cad will be hybrid remember